and I'm going to talk about the bit like
more instrumental side to to the whole
TB issue economics of ecosystem
biodiversity in the past weeks you you
heard a lot about how business can
contribute what wallet voluntary
contributions are available what can
local administrators do etc so I'm going
to do a step back and from the same or
traditional rearm of environmental
economics what are the possible
solutions are element of solutions down
there so if you if you use the kind of
standard phraseology coming from
environmental economics they're
basically two issues they're poor market
failure and policy failure and
biodiversity loss or loss of ecosystems
and associated biodiversity resulting
from that market failure of course this
is a classical thing it's a theory of
externalities why do externalities
persist because there are elements of
public goods including for biodiversity
elements of that's importance not a pure
public good but some elements of
biodiversity have features of public
goods and then you have the classical
approach to say at least the simpler
environmental problems economic
instruments like Pigovian taxes it's
etcetera to internalize these
externalities so I'll discuss that under
the whole under the heading general
heading positive incentives and
regulation and then I come to the other
perspective saying that biodiversity
loss is also result of policy failure
and what can that mean why in that case
we are talking here in particular about
subsidies and their environmentally
harmful effects and what you can do
about that so obviously as you know from
economics there's a certain skeptical
attitude towards regulation having quite
an eminent tradition if you see from the
very
old quote and it has to do with actually
that we have two different notions of
the term regulation and that that's
quite important I'll dwell on that later
on also there is a broad notion and talk
about regulation meaning actually almost
any or certainly any restrictive
governmental intervention and again we
come to the internalization of
externality thing where this important
strand of environmental economics said
okay we need to do something about it
from the government such as pigouvian
tax Environmental Texas etc etc and then
there is of course the narrower
definition or narrower approach of the
notion and that has to do with this
debate many of you might already heard
about this command whereas command and
control instruments versus market-based
or economic instruments so regulation is
then identified as these kind of command
and control instruments which for a
number of reasons are seen as a bit like
crude or not not flexible enough etc I'm
coming back to that so the scope of
regulation it's about setting emissions
performance or management standards it's
about restrictions on product use it's
about also that's very important spatial
planning restricting land use
establishing protected areas this is
this is all a kind of regulation and you
talked I think in the past weeks about
the details of establishment of
protected areas protected area
management etc etc so and the question
now is as a first step how does where's
the delineation between regulation as an
restrictive governmental intervention
and voluntary approaches and in
particular with regard to our topic
biodiversity conservation biodiversity
conservation to say we'll use
so this is a nice actually nice graph
developed by by by Patrick hourly the
editor of the whole team volume on on
policy making for policy makers if you
look at it coming from the from a
situation where you have some
environmental damage to biodiversity to
ecosystem service etcetera you might
have a situation ideal situation where
you have absolutely no control all right
but then even from a purely private
perspective it might actually be useful
and perfectly rational to do some
mitigation avoidance activities costly
mitigation avoidance activities and then
you would you would get to what we might
call a private optimum even in the
absence of any legal requirements or any
state interventions right mind you that
but might not necessarily come about
automatically because say to talk about
a farmer he might not necessarily have
all the information or the technologies
available for say erosion control by
some features of ecosystems so he might
not necessarily do it there might still
be perhaps some policy space to help the
farmer doing it but nothing going beyond
some capacity building certainly not
regulation in there in the narrow sense
so then you can have some legal
requirements kind of spelling out a
reference level and and then that would
be based on some regulatory instrument
which would lead for instance to the
application of the polluter pays
principle and then you might come to a
private solution with legal requirements
so there are some regulations around or
some even economic instruments etc but
that might not necessarily be your
environmental targets why is that well
this is a nice feature or from a
scientific viewpoint nice feature of
biodiversity it's fairly complex and
many aspects of biodiversity are
actually kind of embedded with private
property rights and obviously this
date has only limited powers to
interfere with private property rights
could otherwise constitute what I think
it's the u.s. it's called a regulatory
taking right so you might have
environmental objectives but by simple
government Fiat regulation economic
instruments you can also do so much so
then there comes these voluntary
approaches like payments for ecosystem
service programs where you would perhaps
offer farmers or forest owners further
payments for their continued provision
of ecosystem services even beyond these
kind of legal requirements the legal
reference level so that's the kind of
ideal delineation between regulatory
approaches and voluntary approaches and
of course the political that's what we
said here the practical or political
feasible environmental optimum at the
time that might not necessarily to no
impact I mean if if you we're already at
the other upper frontier then we
wouldn't have a that we would not have a
biodiversity problem right so the the
remaining green square there this is
this is the costs which which continue
to be borne by society and sorry for the
typo Oh
procedurally I forgot to ask you
whenever you I mean whenever you have
the question or you feel that I'm
utterly incomprehensible please don't
don't be shy to ask right away okay so
the question is then why to regulate and
and how to regulate and using again
these two notions I introduced you the
broad notion and the now narrow notion
command controlled versus market-based
instruments why would you or why would
we as a state as a government introduce
some crude standards directly
prescribing individual instead of
introducing a smart environmental text
where everyone is optimizing at the
margin why would we do that Wow
there might be for instance situations
where the regulators the guys who are
going to be regulated by the state they
might be relatively homogeneous right
little difference between producers that
kind of say pollute for instance so in
that case if they are pretty similar
then there will be no little gains from
trade anyways so why should we introduce
a sophisticated for instance tradable
permits scheme when a simple regulatory
standard would also do hmm this is this
is one one of the aspects what they call
the economics of relatively simple tools
this particular applies when you have
many sources tiny bomb on mobile
pollution sources wouldn't be really
practical to to have kind of tradable
permits schemes or something like that
for for your exhaust fumes coming from
your car so I had instead you simply go
ahead and prescribe specific standards
minimum standards for cars sometimes of
course there is simply a need for quite
a quartz corner solutions here right
those of you who did environmentally
economics you you know that typically we
assume these nice curvatures and then
you have an inner optimum right but if
we talk about say hazardous substances
doesn't really make sense right we don't
want to have it wouldn't make sense to
tax plutonium because we simply don't
want it to be around in the environment
so in that sense on that case regulation
would would do better and of course they
are kind of what I call technical issues
here and this is particularly
interesting from a biodiversity
perspective because biodiversity is such
a complex beast as I said it has aspects
of public goods too it has aspects of
private goods to it and it's typically
non-homogeneous so it's very difficult
to tax biodiversity consumption or
landscape consumption
it's possible to attack sulfur dioxide
emissions but for biodiversity they have
to come up with something more like
smarter so we don't have a tax base
unlike for your homogeneous pollutants
and of course we might in many cases
again not necessarily want to have an
inner optimum that's what like what
what's called non convexity x' right
again going back to the curvatures
sometimes we need in a sense extreme
solutions one plot of land where nothing
happens where you have 100% conservation
and another plot of land was the fair
distance in between where a lot of
things happened a lot of economic
activity with potential negative impacts
but the most interesting solution is
actually to separate the two by by way
of spatial planning and by establishment
of protected areas and this is all going
beyond or beyond the traditionary arm of
say thinking about environmental
economics in terms of emission strength
taxation but for biodiversity that
that's a very important aspect and then
of course the third aspect and the one I
want to dwell on a bit further is the
the whole notion of use regulation but
make it smarter by introducing some
add-ons make regulations model so for
instance you can have minimum standards
but then you add something to make it
smaller and how that can look like we're
going to look at in a minute and of
course from an economic perspective
what's what's interesting is is that you
can actually doing add-ons and enhance
efficiency and the typical thing is of
cost readability so have tradable
permits tradable conservation credits
etc so just as a case example I I
thought I pick one as
I said I'm going to dwell on this I
dwell on which might be where you might
be quite familiar with this this is this
whole instrument offsets biodiversity
offsets biodiversity banks so this is my
knowledge not being from the US there
might be some details to fill in here so
if you if you feel that I get something
wrong here please tell me but this is
this is how how I know it works so there
is a section under the Clean Water Act
where where you actually have to get a
permit whenever you you discharge
dredged or fill materials into waters of
the United States and there's a certain
history to that in but the nice thing
what what one would not necessarily
think of in the first glance is is that
water study is that that includes
wetlands and then of course that becomes
very relevant for biodiversity
conservation so when you want to do that
and essentially this is relevant for
almost any development proposed taking
place and wetlands are close to wetlands
you have to get a permit
I think the regulation regulating agency
is the US Army Corp of Engineers and
then the granting of the permit requires
that the the permit e at adheres to this
mitigation sequence so he needs to take
all practicable steps to avoid impacts
avoidance what cannot be avoided needs
to be mitigated has to be minimized and
then the remaining damage and that's the
interesting thing is is to be
compensated by a compensatory measures
compensatory mitigation measure measures
near site or even off site and the whole
idea is that you would implement you can
still if you say if you allow the
development in the first place
compensatory mitigation would contribute
to no net loss of
wetlands so the question now is how to
implement it in the beginning when when
when did that started in fact the
individual developers when went ahead
and tried to you know restore degraded
wetland which wasn't too far away and
then you ended up with many kind of
squareit little restoration plots and
and that led to further thinking and
then there came up this I deal with
metal and mitigation banking where you
can withdraw or establish or enhance
specific larger wetland areas in advance
you can and then you can set them aside
to compensate for further conversions
and the interesting thing is that it can
it's actually a business model because
many of these wetland mitigation banks
that we have been established where is
to have those pipe pipe by entrepreneurs
by private actors so the idea is then if
you propose a development project and
you go through the first two steps and
then you can you you look around just
for them for the last step for the
compensatory mitigation you can purchase
credit from this mitigation Bank and the
price or the value of the credit is
determined by quantifying the wetland
functions or acres restore the creator
so it's it's based on honor honor on
acreage but there are also fairly
extensive regulations with regard how
the ecosystem functions of the wetlands
are ways to have to be restored so the
EPA has a fairly detailed amount of
booklets and guidance brochures etc
etcetera I just looked them up the other
week so yeah you've got a question
yes no the the project developer that's
the project developer has to go through
these phase three steps
avoidance all right bye-bye project
design and then the the impacts that
cannot be avoided have to be mitigated
to the extent feasible on the site and
then there might be some damage left on
the side right I mean if you prepare if
you have a development typically it will
not it will it will have a footprint if
you even if you do the first two steps
and this footprint or this remaining
damage has to be compensated by the
developer so in the case of a vet land
say for instance you proposal
development could be a housing
development for instance or a factory or
whatever and you have some unavoidable
harm some degradation will happen you
will cut off some plots etc say out of
the twenty acres of wetland five will
unavoidably be destroyed well then you
have to go ahead and and restore
somewhere else a degraded wetland and
you might not even have to restore just
five because it's already restored so if
he able say - you have to restore ten or
fifteen right that's that's the idea
behind compensatory mitigation and then
as I said instead of having the
individual developers doing this which
was the way it was done when this
program was implemented first the idea
came up - to kind of get this together
into these kind of mitigation banking
banks enough
what in a sense the this is the thing
yeah it's it's that's what I said it's
still regulation but there is an add-on
here as an individual developer as far
as I know you don't have to go to the
mitigation bank so if you find a smart
compensatory mitigation project nearby
to your site then you can still do it
but you have to do this third step
that's the important thing this is
mandatory but how you do it it might be
that might be your choice and then of
course these these mitigation banks they
provide some more flexibility and the
usual thing is that we would expect more
efficient and more efficient solution so
here there are some of the advantages
that were identified by biodiversity
banks so increase the size of remaining
small ecosystem patches that's what i
said this consolidation reduce ecosystem
fragmentation and also to secure more
reliable biodiversity outcomes because
as I said these biodiversity these days
these wetland banks are created in
advance so in a sense they are already
there and then you can buy in or
developers can buy and later and of
course for the developers it's it that's
advantageous because you know for sure
that if that Bank was already
established and and approved by the EPA
then it's for sure that whatever you go
there by a credit that will be approved
by EPA as well yes and this is of course
I said efficiency because banks have
these economies of scale larger plots
instead of many plush parts etc etc and
you have many banks around so you have
some competition you would expect that
we have a kind of more more cost
effectiveness in achieving the the
environmental goals that goal of no net
loss so this is a typical example where
you would still have regulation in the
narrow sense in a sense and still you
know kind of command and control but
then you ease it up you make it more
flexible
by introducing this kind of trading
training scheme here two examples
whether take place as I said in the US
it's it's I think the u.s. started with
that actually we have now for wetland
banks the market of more than three
billion per year not too bad and
Australia's habitat banking system there
started fairly recently the interesting
thing is that the number of countries
worldwide is very limited doing this
kind of stuff wetland banking for for
sure but even applying that compensatory
mitigation these movies kind of
mitigation hierarchy by law to
developments that's just thirty or
thirty odd states in the world doing
this kind of thing of course it has been
criticized in particular by by by some
environmental NGOs mainly because there
were suspicious of about two things
first first whether whether there would
not lead to a back door that you always
approve projects of course I mean in
principle project can still be too bad
so bad that that that the regulatory
agency should simply reject it but if
you have all this kind nice flex in
mechanisms here there was a suspicion or
there is maybe still up suspicion that
met that may lead to say the agency
approving almost every project to answer
this here you need to do a decent to
empirical study so I can't pronounce
myself on the validity of that argument
but it has been still around and then of
course there are concerns about this
on-site off-site thing because if if the
ecosystem or the kind of species yeah
species associated with the ecosystem
are fairly unique then wouldn't you
compensate apples for oranges that
that's that's not a important very
they're potentially very important point
that was made so in when we had this
discussion and TV came up with this
little kind of
a graph where you can actually identify
a kind of an area where in fact this
kind of offsetting mechanism is not
really inappropriate when you have high
unique endemic species say ecosystem
with high endemism
something better to they're very
difficult to compensate right unless you
really know about the ecosystem
functions and the fact that yes other
species can can can contribute to the
same ecosystem functions etc etc and
losing unique species always critical so
then you may really wonder whether
whether you should do compensation so if
you move on to from from from there to
more like the standard stuff
market-based instruments right taxes
fees charges tradable permits schemes
etc etcetera Wow what they do is I this
is just I mean this is just a standard
yeah I put them up nevertheless it
changed incentives and decision making
yes of course and they have this kind of
built-in nice thing that they that they
achieve cost-effectiveness under under a
specific objective they directly
implement the polluter or user praise
principle they go towards the
internalization of external cost of
course I mean environmental tax is not
necessarily Peruvian tax as you know but
at least the achieve as I said the
targets in a cost-efficient way so we
have this potential cost savings when
compared with emission standards for
instance and of course this that's
important from from a kind of fiscal
environmental fiscal reform perspective
it generates public revenue so and then
there was this idea this quite discussed
quite intensely in some time 15 years
ago that you might actually shift
the tax burden from labor to the
environment in a sense so the idea was
reduce income taxes or other important
Texas and then go for environmental
taxes because it's you know we want to
internalize anyways and the text revenue
you can use by reducing the tax burden
on other Texas and of course that might
have positive impacts on employment etc
etc so that you had this huge discussion
about what this double dividend of doing
this interestingly it's somewhat stalled
right I mean the environmental taxes are
around in a fair amount of oacd
countries but it's still fairly small so
even say Netherlands which Netherlands
Denmark top on the list here they're the
below 10% of all the of the tax receipts
there's not much of course from a
biodiversity perspective as I said there
are limitations to these kind of
instruments as a direct tool for
biodiversity conservation sustainable
use I mean if you look at say taxes on
gas I mean in a sense it would certainly
be helpful for buy reverse sequence
conservation in an indirect way right
less cost less roads etc etc but it's
indirect in a second I'm talking about a
bit on tradable permits schemes and
Fisheries again fish that's fairly
homogeneous right a fish of a certain
species commercial species so and it's
related to biodiversity obviously but
it's just one tiny aspect of marine
biodiversity and then of course in in in
designing this kind of things yes
valuation can improve the design
calibration and
and this kind of economic information
can be can be used then to determine the
adequate tax rate or price right so
here's what I said
individual transferable quotas and
fisheries management they're actually
two steps here the first thing is that
you know fishery is traditionally common
pool resource have some inherent
problems in there which where which
fishery authorities tried to address
through a number of regulatory
approaches and understand that problem
is the race for fish if if you have no
regulation at all every fisherman
fisherwoman tries to take the fish out
first right and the interesting thing is
that under some regulatory approaches
this problem will persist so if you have
a fishing season then they go out with
all-out with their boats and try to get
as many fish as possible and then you
you have to narrow and narrow down the
the period for the fishing season as
your resource gets more and more under
threat gear restrictions right then I
had this kind of regulatory approaches
trying to restrict the gear or the
vessel capacity and and then you've got
this cat-and-mouse play between the
regulatory agency and the inventiveness
of the fish a fork trying to come up
with still neither technical means to
get up get out as many fish as possible
so the nice and fairly innovative in the
time approach was to provide fishers
with defined rights within a given
fishery based on total allowable catch
for the entire fishery so you would
assign catch shares that that's the
general name for that that's already a
huge step forward because then you you
actually make a huge a big step towards
solving or addressing this race to the
fish problem
and then an additional you can make
these catchers tradable to account for
you know technical or technological
differences between the fisherfolk
etcetera etcetera and then again you can
enhance efficiency because you allow
traits from gains from trade to be
realized so this is actually a that's an
interesting thing here this is actually
fairly old stories we resource
economists fishery economists have been
advocating IT queues for you know when
when I was studying that was still that
was already standard textbook fare and
it's interesting to see the time lap
between this kind of fairly standard
economic system and the application
implementation and actual management
thing is that many policymakers don't
really listen to economists it takes a
long time to to get that message down
now you have a fairly significant and
increasing number of fisheries applying
catch shares and some even using
full-blown IT queues so what's what's
nice that you have now the empirical
information at hand to to redo an
empirical assessment right I mean it's
as I said policymakers rarely believe
economic theories but they might be more
inclined to believe solid empirical
study so I was referring here to one
article in science 2008 which actually
did just that they empirically assessed
a large amount of fisheries they put it
into a database
both the actually cash statistics and
the institution of the management
arrangement in place and they came up
with fairly solid empirical conclusion
that yes in fact implementation of catch
shares holds that even reverses the
global trend towards
towards fisheries fishery collapse and
in addition it may also improve
compliance and participation management
so that's actually again quite a nice
quite a nice story and and again an
example where you can address some
aspects of biodiversity
bye-bye-bye smart regulation of course
monitoring enforcement this is more like
for being comprehensive here this is
always a problem right
I mean it's mind you this it's all it's
still by a government even if it's smart
even if you have markets it's still by
government Fiat so the individual fish
of fork mic might always have a an
incentive to cheat however it's it's
also probably true that the incentive to
cheat is even higher if you just
penalize because if you provide positive
incentives so they have the incentives
to cheat and the positive incentives
because you can get to take the positive
incentives and still do your harmful
activity right it's not going away the
problems not going away but it might be
less there might be less inclined you
approaches to approach cases of non
non-compliance again interestingly in
the past you had many environmental
regulations which lead to led to kind of
unexpected outcomes and economic
thinking can actually help you in in
perhaps prevent these unexpected
outcomes then that example was happened
in many developing countries when when
you had elephants wildlife humans
wildlife conflicts right so maybe you
have big forest feral elephants are
living there or some other wildlife and
then you have farmers nearby
and you had conflict and the government
wanted to preserve the wild species
what they did was typically to introduce
regulation forbidding the farmers to do
anything about that to do not interfere
right and then they had the typical
monitoring enforcement constraints
basically no capacity in place for
properly monitor and enforced it that
that regulation and the thing is in many
instances this wildlife is really a big
nuisance right elephants go into your
fields trample them down and eat the
harvest so the typical approach of my
farmers was what was called shoot shovel
and shut up and remarkably this was not
expected not expected initially by by
the regulator so and then eventually
once they realized the problem then they
came up with you know these additional
schemes and again economic thinking can
help to design these schemes in a useful
way such as
compensation schemes for for wildlife
damage etc etc and of course for many
environmental or biodiversity issues the
issue is actually trans boundary
monitoring as trans boundary enforcement
needs to be trans boundary so you need
this international collaboration and
then I put I found that nice opportunity
to put a nice slide on on my employer
the United Nations or the CBD and talk
about the role of international law and
and multilateral environmental
agreements in general and as you see
this is one of their all to address
these kind of trans boundary monitoring
enforcement issues but here's just a
couple of empirical information you have
an awful lot of them around if you count
really the really small-scale regional
or maybe even sub regional agreements
might have over 500 nobody know nobody
knows there
exactly I'm not probably well of course
we have the big ISA and I mentioned the
real conventions here the ones that were
signed and adopted the real conference
the the United Nations conference on
Environment and development in Rio in
1992 and my convention the CBD is one of
them together with the conventions on to
combat desertification climate change
and then specifically for the
biodiversity rearm we have these five
here the biodiversity global
biodiversity conventions CBD sides--
migratory species the Rams our
Convention on wetlands and the world
heritage convention under under UNESCO
it's a fairly diverse lot doing
completely different things and and
doing these completely different things
in a completely different manner quite
interesting let's have a look at try to
categorize a bit what these guys are
doing
of course the whole the idea is that
whenever you have a trans boundary or
regional or global issue then yes states
need to come together and agree on some
stuff to do about it and there's of
course the notion yes environmental
assets as a as an international public
good climate changes or the climate
global climate is the kind of slanted
example but then distinct from that
there might be actually also a need for
these kind of treaties whenever you have
this need for trans boundary enforcement
so whenever you need to ensure
compliance across borders even if the
problem itself is or put it otherwise
even if it's just the national interest
alone to do something about it
so in that case it's maybe a national
public good but not necessarily an
international one
but the compliance issue might be an
international issue it's that important
example I put here is IDs
a conventional international trade and
in dangerous species of wild flora fauna
and flora so the idea is whenever trade
contributes to further endanger or
threatened endangered species you need
to do something about it inside is what
situs does is essentially is it's a
permit system and restricting permits
depending on on the degree of threat to
the species but the important thing is
that the site is certificate is then
used for checking monitoring and
enforcement across borders and that's
the unique global system force for
permits mind you that preserving an
individual species of wildlife that's
national interest it's not necessarily
public global public good nevertheless
the enforcement issue is international
in dimension so that's why you need the
the convention it's actually that that's
why I put these two distinct issues here
so this is the kind of standard thing
the first thing people think about when
they think about environmental law but
what the point I wanted to make is that
actually they they are also helpful for
other stuff what I call they provide a
platform for cooperation first of all to
agree on the detail on what needs to be
done including on substantial or
procedural standards etc and then this
is important a foreign going back to
this global public good thing from an
economic from a naive economic
perspective it's actually surprising
that these meas are agreed on in the
first place because if it's public good
a global public good then everyone has a
dominant incentive to free right right
isn't it so why does it come about in
the first place well we have more
sophisticated economic theories we that
can I also explain that but it's less
surprising from an economic perspective
from that economic perspective that meas
often don't
really work that well right as you all
know I mean it's just newspaper
knowledge so it's good still to have
them to pride a visible platform for
international commitments because then
at least later on NGOs can go and blame
lazy governments and you might have some
you know reputational loss if everything
works works well from from the
environment perspective but they also
helpful to establish and depth
mechanisms for implementation including
for monitoring and enforcement that what
relating back to the second point here
the second point above under one trans
boundary enforcement and this is the
last point this is important in
particular for the CBD the CBD is really
a kind of global Framework Convention so
the provisions in the CBD are fairly
general because it's a big world people
are doing different things in different
corners of the world and what's useful
is to have this platform to exchange
experiences in implementation learn from
learning from each other right
identifying good practices lessons
learned etc etc in particular given that
we have this kind of fairly different
regulatory and policy approaches
throughout the globe I mentioned earlier
that this did these biodiversity offset
policies which are fairly standard in
the US and a couple of other states are
still fairly innovative and new to the
bulk of states of the globe so there is
still considerable say leeway for
learning from each other and to realize
gains again gains from trade from
learning in a sense this is the work on
incentive measures under the CBD and the
important thing is that this little
article here this this serves as the
kind of entry point to the economic work
under the another Convention but you see
it's fairly general and note that the
little almost disclaimer
as far as possible as appropriate of
course that's what they say is here
incentive measures meaning for instance
economic instruments that's not for
everyone and not for every situation but
then you can spell out and try to find
out what is the situation where it is
appropriate and that's what the CBD is
doing under its program of work on
incentive measures and what we do at the
international level
you know organize this exchange of
experiences in cetera et cetera and teeb
the whole process of teeb is an
international initiative contribute to
that that that's kau how it's linked in
and to the CBD and the team of cheap
results were then taken up in the CBD so
this is what I wanted to say on on
regulation and now let's turn to that
important other thing not market failure
but policy failure before I do so is
there any know-how you're fine huh
yeah no
you know what we are thinking about that
yes there are two aspects here the first
aspect is can you really do this
biodiversity offsets in it on an
international or global or at least
trans boundary manner again right the
the kind of initial or immediate answer
is by many people is say sound
skepticism because of this uniqueness
aspect of biodiversity and the risk that
you might trade I don't know
pandas for Tigers which of course you
could not do it you should not do but
having said that there might perhaps be
opportunities to further expand or
scale-up this kind of thing there is an
initiative looking into this and and we
as a secretariat we were also involved
in the debate it's it's called let me
just think this these acronyms I come
back to you on it I'm just I'm blocked
here but I did as I said there is an
initiative looking looking looking
looking into this issue and trying to
come up with the kind of international
scheme perhaps trading scheme for for
for for biodiversity offsets and also
trying to look into how you could have
some pilot cases bringing a couple of
countries together
remember me I need to come back to that
now subsidies we're forming subsidies
I've put up this nice oacd quote which
in a sense brings about the main message
of of my talk here and here's the
structure what I want to do so let's
have a first look at what is actually a
subsidy and if you look at this closer
it's actually not easy to come up with a
definition or maybe it's not possible to
come up with one single definition
globally you have a couple of
established definitions from OCD
statistics division of the UN and and
the WTO but you have differences among
them quite remarkable differences the
one difference is whether it's just for
producers or whether it's also for
consumers under some circumstances the
second difference is whether it's just
payment or as whether it's more than
payments you see the statistic division
definitions talks just about payments
that's very narrow oacd is rather broad
it talks about any government action
that confers an advantage WTO talks
about a financial contribution which is
again bit narrow but the financial
contribution can also be a tax rebate
for instance but tax rebate is not a
payment
strictly speaking so you see the
differences here of course these
definitions we are all designed for the
for the specific purposes of the
organisations involved
so for the tip study the treviri adopted
a very broad definition but of course we
need to be clear that it's a fairly
loaded term right subsidy you need to
think critically about the agenda the
subsidy reform agenda in particular when
you talk about consumer subsidies health
care big topic in the u.s. is that is
that a subsidy or is it not I'm not
providing an answer right I'm coming
from Canada mind you so what what as I
said 40 we adopted a fairly broad
subsidy a definition or
conceptualization I'm coming to the up
coming back to that what's important to
realize is that this indeed they come in
many shapes and forms talk about direct
transfer of funds but also potential
direct transfer right of reliability
restriction for for nuclear accidents
that that was a the pet talk of my of my
fellow Patrick we did both a chapter and
and he was fairly adamant on this one
but can also be as I said tax exemption
tax rebates tax credits for fuel a
particular low interest loans and
guarantees preferential treatment use of
regular support mechanisms demand quotas
trade trade barriers tariffs can act
like a subsidy and then of course
implicit income transfer where natural
resources services are not priced at
full cost they're not even talked about
external cost you're talking about
provisioning costs might cost of piping
clean water to the consumer so if you've
come to an evaluation of subsidy what we
have to realize and in the tip we said
okay we're not going to put out the baby
with the bathwater and we we say we will
acknowledge that this is the main tool
of governments to to dole out money to
do good things but the question really
is whether the subsidy helps to
serve towards the intended purpose its
intended policy objective and we have
many instances where the policy
objectives aren't that clear in the
first place but even if the proclaim
policy objectives are there you can
pinpoint fairly easily that the subsidy
doesn't really contribute to that I
provide an example later on then of
course the question is about efficiency
at what cost how a cost-benefit
distributed and then fuss of particular
relevance
are there any harmful consequences for
the environment what's important to say
here is that we do have many green
subsidies right I mean payment programs
for purposely green objectives
environmental objectives and in
principle that this assessment criteria
needs to be applied to green subsidies
as well now environmental harmful
subsidies what we said here we build we
use the OECD definition and then we said
okay but in doing so we have an
environmentally harmful effect how can
that come along that environmental
helpful effect there are actually two
general mechanisms typically many many
subsidies actually provide a reduction
for input costs or increase revenues and
consumer subsidies lead then to the
below-cost pricing for the use of the
natural resource in question and then
this in turn leads to incentives for the
increased use of subsidized resources
increase production consumption level
increased environmental damage here's
some numbers on globally this is
actually a mistake well no not really
but you need to know careful I don't
think that the 261 billion per year this
is all environmentally harmful subsidies
this is all subsidies but then I said
you see it 151 of those so roughly one
hundred thirty thousand one hundred
thirty billion sorry increased
production so because they're tied to in
or increased revenue to farmers etc so
in that sense there is a strong
suspicion that there might be some
environmentally harmful impact behind it
same for fisheries bulk of the fishery
subsidies contribute to over capacity
and then over as I will argue later on
over capacity that's identified as being
an important driver of declining fish
stocks etcetera etc of course we do have
conceptual data challenges this desire
estimates but there and particular
agriculture fisheries energy these are
fairly good and fairly recent estimates
for water unfortunately I didn't I
didn't find a particularly recent one so
there we have more more say more of a
challenge where we also have a challenge
is that in identifying or quantifying
the exact impact of the harmful subsidy
on the ecosystem services and on
biodiversity first of all because we
have priced different price elasticity
elasticity zhan different markets so if
you want to come up with a solid number
then that's difficult then you have also
this leakage issue where you know
subsidized sectors the the effects
leaked on to other to other sectors or
other markets and to identify the entire
effect then is fairly challenging
because it can go away from the initial
from the initial market and then of
course there is the genuinely scientific
problem that ecosystem functioning is
still not fairly not not not fully
understood so we don't really know to
what extent say specific degradation in
ecosystems lead to a specific
degradation ecosystem functioning and
ecosystem services and last but not
least there are a couple of intervening
factors including policy factors so
there might be actually policy measures
in place which kind of mitigate the
harmful in
pects and if you don't take those into
consideration then we might actually
overemphasize the environmental impacts
so this is the kind of the the
conceptual difficulties if you want to
come up with a specific number or
specific quantification of the effect of
subsidies on biodiversity what's
important to note is in general terms is
that the size of the subsidy does not
necessarily reflect the extent of its
harmful effect meaning that small
subsidies can actually have a big effect
in the tip study we had the the example
of of modern bottom trawling the
subsidies for bottom trawling are
actually fairly low its two-digit
millions I think but but the
environmental impact of bottom trawling
of causes is huge so here's here's a
nice number of nice cases on subsidies
which are actually not very effective or
targeted against against their
objectives you look at fuel subsidies
energy subsidies often what said that
you help the poor right its subsidies
are given because you want to do some
poverty alleviation or you know do
simply Social Policy and the interesting
thing is that in many cases the
subsidies are actually a subsidy for the
middle class and yes the poor also
profit from them but disproportionately
lower than the middle classes so we have
that study here from from from the World
Bank and and the numbers are actually
fairly nice and of course those
subsidies that do not even fulfill its
of their objectives and you could end
they might have environmentally harmful
effects you could argue that those might
be nice candidates for proud
to reform so just a couple of slides on
subsidies in select sectors agriculture
fisheries water I said it's difficult to
quantify but at least you can point at
the kind of main drivers coming from
subsidies and from ads and in in in case
of Agriculture's actually fairly neat
its intensification and its expansion so
intensification yeah you have this this
kind of bullet list here loss of
non-target species as a by-product I do
you want to kill pests and then all the
birds drop of the trees and these kind
of things and then expansion expansion
is a bit more difficult of course the
standard thing is that you expand areas
into forests and apparently agricultural
frontier etc so and if you're losing
more natural ecosystems then it leads to
ecosystem degradation vice versa you
would expect that if we reduced the
subsidy that would then lead to our
cultural contraction and eventually if
you put conservation policies in place
you could actually restore the regular
degraded ecosystems so in that sense you
might have positive impacts for
ecosystems biodiversity the interesting
twist and the debate here is that that
might not always be the case because it
actually may have extensive farming
regions where traditional farming
practices play a key role in preserving
some aspects of Agriculture biodiversity
and if those are taken out of
construction you may actually lose by
diversity so we talked about this high
nature of value farmlands here and I
provided some examples so you have a
certain shop policy challenge right if
you reduce subsidies or cultural
subsidies yes you can gain
if you put conservation policies in
place but you would also need to make
sure that you preserve these kind of
high natural value farmlands and in that
case you actually ensure ongoing our
cultural production there so there's a
certain policy challenge in in meeting
two objectives on agricultural subsidies
we can actually see some some progress
in reform and and it has to do with the
fact that in the past two decades yeah
15 years there has been a kind of
ongoing effort by many governments to
decouple agricultural subsidies what's
meant with that is that instead of
having subsidies which in hand that are
directly linked to inputs or outputs you
provide subsidies in a way that are
which are decoupled from from
agricultural production that's the idea
for instance general income support that
would be in decoupled from production so
presumably would be less environmental
health less environmentally harmful and
that has actually taken place and you
can see that fairly well in the indeed
in the OECD statistics where the Kapil
support the share of the couple support
went went down quite substantially in
the last 20 years together with also the
share of support and total farm revenues
however that later number of course you
also need to take into account that we
had rising food prices and that might
actually be the single most important
aspect to that not necessarily progress
on the reform on the reform side
obviously more needs to be done the
progress is uneven among countries but
also see even if even half p51 is to a
couple to
action that's still an enormous amount
it is still one as I said 130 billion US
dollars per year it's quite a lot of
money and because of that sheer amount
it's also important to note that this
decoupling will never be complete if you
look at the analytical the analysis
undertaken by OECD they point out that
if you have really big number
you always have effect on production
even if it's formally you know not tied
to your inputs or outputs fisheries wow
I guess you all know about the dire data
with regard to global fish stocks and
the important thing is that yes
subsidies contribute to that in
particular those that are capacity
enhancing so enhancing the capacity of
fishing fleet so I've provided a couple
of examples here what the subsidies do
for fleet expansion modernization grants
low-interest loans etc etc and what's
also major trunk and related to the
energy side is tax preferences for fuel
particular for fishing vessels that's an
important that's actually an important
in many many countries an important
aspect and these fisheries subsidies
really have them they can really have a
fairly detrimental impact and the
interesting thing is even from a purely
financial perspective a couple of EC
countries fishery subsidies are higher
in the country than the actual landing
revenue so subsidy to the fishing sector
is more than what the fish is actually
worth on the market the fish harvested
and landed in that particular country
this is quite
interesting economic data this is by the
way I didn't put that here but it's from
the from the EC white book on on on fun
on fisheries water yeah as I said water
is actually the bulk he is not even
internalization but its below-cost
pricing or even pre free provisioning of
water and of course it can that can lead
to overuse of water simply waste of
water and it's a particularly particular
concern of course in arid or semi-arid
areas when when water is available
plentiful might not be the best way to
do it from a financial management
perspective perhaps but then it's more
like of a limited problem and mind you
that water saving if you save too much
then can actually have detrimental
impacts you have raising costs because
the this the sewer starts to sink in
summer like if you don't have enough
water running through it you may have
higher maintenance problems you made
actually fly need to flush it with water
etc etc so there are some interesting
twists here but in certainly in in many
developing countries in in arid and
semi-arid areas in it can can lead to
two important problems not necessarily
only in developing countries I mean
southern Spain has severe problems with
with water shortages etc and also it's
another nice example where the even the
proclaimed objective again helped the
poor right the urban poor most of the
urban poor and developing countries
don't have access to pipe water in the
first place so in in a sense you know
these water below cost pricing water is
really subsidy to the middle class again
and then in developing countries that
can actually need to cash-strapped
utilities then and they don't have
enough water
Minoo
enough money to expand their network to
the slums so it's in developing
countries in in in arid and semi-arid
areas you can make it's a very strong
point about that and irrigation
subsidies are particularly concerning
obviously from a biodiversity
perspective energy I mentioned I wanted
to mention that here because it's it's
such an important subsidy component but
of course for fossil fuels the impact on
biodiversity is only indirect right
through climate change etcetera etc
there is the important case of biofuel
subsidies I just put that here as a
bullet because that to treat that
decently you need a known nature it
depends on so many things the generation
of biofuels what kind of crop you use
etc etc but you can say that many
subsidies provided in particular in just
in in OECD countries merit further
scrutiny let's put it that way and you
can also say that my is is not the best
crop to produce biofuels that that's for
sure so against that Wow some reform
efforts are taking place but it's really
really very slow and very protected and
of course that has to do with the
political economy of subsidy reform it
can also to have to do in in some
circumstances with technological
institutional barriers informational
barriers governments are doing so many
things and having so many programs and
often really very difficult or
challenging to disentangle the different
effects of different programs and even
the stated policy objectives are rarely
cleared the typical approach is that it
has been around for 20 years and many
people are happy with that and it's not
exactly sure why are you doing it but
you stakeholders are happy
it's a tracer so you continue doing it
right
so that's why we said that actually an
important first step is to do a decent
subsidy inventory and then an assessment
on the different effects and trying to
disentangle the different effects
including on the environment we do have
quite I mean the OECD worked on that
extensively in the past 10-15 years and
we do have existing guidance and
checklists etc for for for governments
or government officials who are keen to
to move on that various to reform
alright there's of course vested
interests right I mean that goes without
saying
but often mind you it's often different
to disentangle what's really just
lobbying and what's genuine and and
honest concerns about stakeholders who
was going or we're going to lose right
let me talk about fishery subsidies do
you really let the fishery villages
there go astray and they just go under
or do you do something about it maybe
some decent training or relocation
programs etc etc so whatever not
everything you might come up with as a
kind of compensatory program if you face
all the subsidies it's just for the
purpose of giving more pork to the to
the to the entrenched stakeholders and
then of course there are these genuine
political considerations development
prerogatives food security you have to
face you sometimes you face trade-offs
you need to think how about that
here look there and as I said there are
a number of interesting and successful
cases of policy reform subsidy reform
and even subsidy complete subsidy
removal and you can draw some lessons
learned from from that this is this is
base that it was the bulk of the OECD
work I mentioned so what here are kind
of standard lessons learned for
successful reform of course you need to
have yes a transparent definition of
policy objectives and the long term plan
this ambitious end points but timetables
for reform might be cautious of course
this can also mean that you give another
extension another extension another
extension etcetera etcetera this is why
we actually put also here use political
windows of opportunity it's quite
interesting you find success stories for
both cases and the New Zealand case
where they really removed a lake house
and fishery subsidies there was like a
big bang solution they did that in a
couple of years and and and the the
underlying factors was that they had a
huge economic crisis and essentially
couldn't pay it anymore so they got a
change of government and it said it was
a bit like as I said a nice political
window of opportunity but you don't
necessarily need to have that and that's
why I put the Norwegian case which were
almost much also on fishery subsidies
which were much more gradual and step by
step and more you might say I don't know
conciliatory less adversive it really
depends a bit then on also on the on the
policy style yeah and then I put this
year on the role of transitional support
I'm I said that earlier it's not always
pork for stakeholders it can really be
useful if you want to do something for
the affected communities so job training
buyouts early retirement etc etc
they a couple of international
agreements around I mentioned earlier
that that that one of the say advantages
of meas is that they provide a platform
for these agreements and I provided two
examples here the one is from the g20
but Pittsburgh summit where they
solemnly declare to phase out fossil
fuel subsidies unfortunately there is no
timeline there I was a bit disappointed
when I looked it up because I thought
that there was a timeline but there
wasn't there is a timeline however in
the strategic plan for biodiverse you
adopted by it by the CBD crop last year
so they say that by 2020 they want to
Ellen made phase-out or reform
incentives including subsidies that are
harmful for biodiversity that's nice huh
consistent in harmony with the
convention and other relevant
international obligation that refers in
particular to the WTO because the WTO
under their doha work program also have
a negotiating mandate on agricultural
subsidy and fishery subsidies and taking
into account national social economic
condition that of course we first back
to the genuine political considerations
I mentioned a few minutes ago
development prerogatives etc this was
meant to keep policy space for
developing countries if they want to
continue using fertilizer subsidies for
instance to develop their their
aquaculture that's the idea so
nevertheless this is a quite useful
commitment let's let's hope and let's
work towards its effective
implementation here's a bit like like an
outlook right what can we do short-term
and what can we do long-term as I said
the first step in many countries is
actually could come up with some kind of
transparent comprehensive subsidy
inventories and then do kind of an
assessment of what the effects actually
are both on the environments
and then on the side of the stated
objectives are there really effectual
many of those presumably are not and
then you may come up with an action plan
for pro-choice prioritized phase-out or
reform and use political opportunities
there's one thing I've forgot here you
need to put that what what's really
helpful in in in in many cases is
actually transparency or traps public
transparency on sub subsidy programs
it's immensely opposed by stakeholders
but the U for instance had a regulation
a couple years ago that that all member
states have to come up with the public
inventory of subsidies including the
recipients and G some countries we are
really dragging their feet and within
the country's specific provinces in my
country for instance some provinces
worried dragging their feet because they
had important agricultural sectors
etcetera so it helps a lot because it it
it informs public debate and if you know
really what you're talking about and
where the subsidies go can have quite an
impact on on the political debate then
in longer term of course there is the
kind of a broader environmental fiscal
reform agenda reorient
Freed France for instance for payments
for ecosystem services provision of fans
to expand the protected area and network
and investment ecological infrastructure
restoration equals the large square
ecosystem in the restoration that would
be the kind of the program for the
future well with that I'm I'm at the end
of my talk I mean it's just reading the
newspaper the last days I mean you would
think that policymakers are more
concerned about saving the euro or
saving the banking system and the
financial sector but I would hope that
this would
come back to the agenda even on the on
the newspapers so with that thank you
very much